أصدرت إدارة شرطة لويزفيل كنتاكي متروبوليتان
لقطات للشرطة والمارة من إطلاق النار في
البنك الوطني القديم يوم الاثنين،
توقف هنا، احتياطي احتياطي هنا،
الفيديو الأول هو من
كاميرا جسد الضابط نيكولاس ويلت ويظهر فيلت
والضابط كوري جالواي يصلان إلى
تم إطلاق رصاصتين في المشهد ثم
خرج الاثنان من سيارتهما واقتربا من المبنى
[موسيقى]
بعد ذلك،
الفيديو الثاني مأخوذ من كاميرا جسد جالواي
عندما اقترب الضباط من
المبنى ويمكن سماع المزيد من الطلقات وشوهد
جالواي وهو يسقط على الأرض.
يركض على الدرج ويختبئ
خلف زارع بالقرب من الشارع
رائع
[موسيقى]
الله ليس لديه زاوية أعتقد
أنني نزلت أعتقد أنه في الأسفل،
أنت ميت الآن اسحبه إلى أسفل
الدرج،
جالواي في النهاية قادر على ذلك  شاهد وأطلق
النار على المسلح
ثم اقترب من المبنى وركض بجوار
ويلت الذي أصيب بجروح خطيرة على يد
المسلح كونور ستورجيون البالغ من العمر 25 عامًا،
نعم المشتبه به، أنزل الضابط،
هاه،
أدخل الضابط جالواي إلى
المبنى وشوهدت جثة سمك الحفش على
الأرض،
ما رأيته  في هذا الفيديو
كان مذهلاً للغاية، إنه مأساوي
ولكنه مدهش للغاية،
هناك عدد قليل فقط من الأشخاص في هذا
البلد يمكنهم فعل ما فعلوه، قُتل خمسة
أشخاص على يد المسلح وأصيب
ثمانية آخرون، بما في ذلك
الضابط المبتدئ فيلت الذي كان في
حالة حرجة مع  كان أصيب بطلق ناري في
رأس
سمك الحفش موظفًا بدوام كامل في
البنك لمدة عامين تقريبًا وفقًا
لملفه الشخصي على LinkedIn وفقًا
لمصدر إنفاذ القانون، وقد تم إخطاره
بأنه سيتم فصله، لكن
عمدة لويزفيل وصف هذا الادعاء بأنه
غير دقيق بناءً على  المعلومات
المقدمة له من أحد المسؤولين في
البنك